What about all the different
variations of fonts?
A font family, or
even a family of families can
contain dozens of variations.
First, Roboto actually has
four distinct font families,
including a condensed, monospace and
even an older slab serif family.
Within each font family you
have a variety of weights.
Font weight is the relative
thickness of each letter.
The most common weights are regular and
bold, but
really great fonts will come in light,
thin, regular, medium, bold or black.
And now these can go by different names,
like semi-bold or ultra-thin.
Weights often also get numbers
assigned to them, from 0 to 1000,
where the thinnest weights have
something like 100 value, and
the darkest or the thickest
weights have a 900 or 1000 value.
And finally, each of these
weights normally has a normal and
an italic style.
Now when it comes to
styling text in Android,
the terminology is a little different.
If you're using Roboto, text views have
two attributes that let you customize
the font, fontFamily and textStyle.
FontFamily let's you choose
which family to use and
the specific weight,
such as thin or light.
And textStyle let's you choose italics,
but it also let's you make the text bold.
You should generally avoid using
textStyle to make text bold and
instead use the fontFamily attribute,
since you'll have more control
over the exact weight to use.
Also note that not every weight
is available in every family.
For example as of this writing, Roboto
condensed doesn't include a thin and
a black weight.
Here's some sample code for
applying a font family in text style.
Here we're saying to use
the condensed family but italicized.
And here are some other examples
of values you can use for
fontFamily to set the fontFamily or
the weight, like thin, medium, light.
Now, one quick note with
the condensed fonts,
the Roboto Condensed example here.
You can squeeze a lot more text into the
same horizontal space with these fonts,
but condensed fonts can
definitely be overused.
They're not quite as legible and
don't always look great with
other wider fonts, like Roboto Regular,
or even wider fonts than that.
So definitely be careful when using
condensed fonts as your font family.